i have some very interesting information
i want to share with you related to
synthetic vitamins from my viewpoint
synthetic vitamins should not be taken
on a regular basis
for
increasing your health now if you're
taking them for a detoxification program
that's something completely different
but taking them on a regular basis month
after month after month
could create some problems so we're
going to talk about why and the reason
i'm bringing this up is because 98
of all vitamins sold are made
synthetically
and the question is are they the same as
natural vitamins and the answer is no
because just because it's similar does
not make it
identically the same that's like saying
an artificial flavoring is exactly the
same as a natural flavoring it's not
of all the ascorbic acid or synthetic
version of vitamin c is comes from china
and the regulation of what you're
getting might not be at the standards
that you really need as well especially
since vitamin c is made from gmo corn
with
other chemicals other solvents now
ideally the best way to get your
nutrients is through food nutrient dense
foods but it's very difficult to find
foods with all the nutrients that you
need
but the other thing to know is that your
own microbes in your gut make vitamins
now the actual form
of a synthetic vitamin versus a natural
vitamin is different now i don't want to
get into the complexities
of synthetic vitamins but when you have
synthetic vitamins some of that vitamin
is in a different form so when it goes
to your body like a lock and a key
it's not going to fit so as a good
portion of that vitamin is going to be
wasted so the absorption rate or the
bioavailability of the synthetic vitamin
is is lower and this is why you see the
synthetic vitamins in massive amounts
like
11 000
percent of your rdas and so a lot of
that's going to be passing out through
your urine unless it's fat soluble and
with synthetic vitamins you don't have
all the cofactors
that normally come with a vitamin in
nature vitamins and nature are complexes
and they have a lot of helper molecules
they don't come in this industrial
isolated
fractionated part they come in this
synergistic complexity of a lot of
different parts which includes like they
might have a trace mineral part of that
vitamin they'll have other vitamins that
help the absorption and one reason for
this is because let's just take
antioxidants
when an antioxidant donates its electron
to a free radical which is basically
something that has that's unpaired in
other words it it's missing an electron
so the antioxidant donates this electron
to make this free radical stable well
now that antioxidant becomes
a free radical because now it's missing
an electron so it has to borrow electron
from a friend or neighbor antioxidant so
if you don't have a network of
antioxidants you can basically turn your
antioxidants into free radicals so this
is why mother nature always comes in
a group
of antioxidants and associated helper
molecules now the other really big
problem
with the synthetic vitamins is that they
have residual
traces of
some of the solvents
chemical compounds
like chloroform petroleum
acetate glyphosate which is an herbicide
and even hexane which is a solvent but
in nature you're not going to find that
at all now the thing with vitamins is
they come in both fat soluble forms and
water soluble forms so if you took a
high amount of a water soluble synthetic
vitamin the extra would be eliminated
through your kidneys but if it's a fat
soluble vitamin it's not going to be
eliminated very easily it's going to get
stuck in your fat cells and this is why
there's some pretty major side effects
when you take synthetic fat-soluble
vitamins so if a mother is taking
synthetic vitamin a there's a risk for
that child of having a birth defect
there's some data on synthetic vitamin e
and premature death and then folic acid
which is different than the natural
version folate increasing your risk of
getting cancer then you have vitamin c
okay i'm talking about scorpic acid
there's a study that i'll put down below
that shows that it decreases the muscle
mitochondria biogenesis so you're going
to make less mitochondria so you're
going to have less training efficiency
but i will say that there's also some
positive benefits
of
taking
synthetic vitamin c in the form of
ascorbate
injected
for cancer now i'm not recommending this
but there's just some interesting data
to show that
it can help kill cancer cells because it
can turn into hydrogen peroxide in your
blood
and kill the cancer now again i'm not
telling you to do that i'm just showing
you that there is studies that show
there's benefits of synthetic vitamins
but even folic acid in prenatals can
decrease the risk of getting neural tube
defects so that would be one benefit but
there's side effects of increasing risk
for cancer so there's pros and cons but
there's way more pros when you do the
natural
whole food concentrates now with
synthetic vitamins
they add a lot of additional things in
there they'll add additives
preservatives flavorings colorings so
let me just read you the ingredient list
on probably one of the most
popular highest selling synthetic
vitamins on the market
okay it has modified corn starch
i don't know why they put modified corn
starch
in a vitamin maltodextrin which is sugar
polydextrose ascorbic acid vitamin a
acetate which is synthetic then they add
yellow six leg
as a coloring agent and then some of the
minerals are in oxide forms which
are not the best absorbed
minerals if possible you want the
plant-based minerals or minerals that
are absorbed a lot better then they add
calcium carbonate which is basically
rocks
and ascorbic acid now of course i'm not
biased in my own vitamins but i'll show
you the
the vitamin c ingredients in mine
organic freeze-dried acerola cherry
fruit organic freeze-dried strawberry
fruit organic freeze-dried acai berry
fruit organic freeze-dried blueberry
fruit and let's talk about my keto
energy product
vitamin a from carrots vitamin c from
blueberry cranberry
and strawberry
vitamin d from shiitake mushrooms
vitamin e from tomatoes vitamin k1 from
spinach
vitamin b2 from broccoli you see
especially with the b vitamins like
vitamin b1 b2
they make it from coal tar acetone and
ammonia versus the natural version can
come from garlic or nutritional yeast
vitamin b2 could be from holy basil
vitamin a could be from cod liver oil
but the problem with natural vitamins is
it's more difficult to extract it's more
expensive but you need a lot less of it
because it's way more bioavailable and
it has a lot less side effects so i
think one way to identify synthetic
vitamins is to look at the rdas and the
back of the label and if it's in very
high amounts
then you know it's probably synthetic so
anyway i wanted to give you some basic
information about the difference between
synthetic and natural vitamins and if
you can go for the natural vitamins or
even better yet eat foods that are
nutrient dense now for more information
on foods that are nutrient dense
this is the next video you need to watch
right here